thing as tenuous is that what is the
basis for it legally well if it falls
into the area of one the intelligence
jurisdiction of the activities of the
Communist Party you have a situation
where an individual in an organization a
leader of an organization efforts are
being made to influence him and achieve
control over the organization and it's
part of the overall investigation of the
party trying to exert this influence as
to are they successful are they taking
over the black movement or the civil
rights movement it's no it look like we
try to make clear in investigations that
were more prevalent years ago but still
occur in communist influence and labor
unions we try to tell everybody we
interview we're not interested in labor
matters we're not trying to inquire into
that we're interested in the effect of
the Communist Party on this Union mr.
Adams I'm trying to get at the legal
basis in this particular case of
investigating dr. King on the grounds
that he might be subject to communist
influence can you cite any legal basis
for that or is it based entirely upon a
generalized Authority thought produced
in the FBI to investigate quote internal
security matters it would fall also in
the presidential directives of
investigating subversive activities and
then the question would return to what
authority the President had that's right
for such an order now dr. King was
investigated among other things are for
matters of I think you call it delicacy
would that be a basis for investigating
a American citizen by the FBI now would
you say then that those investigations
were improper
i-i don't believe that there is an
allegation that we investigated him for
that I think there were certain
byproducts of information that developed
and I think that at a point you have a
situation where the tail was wagging the
dog perhaps but I don't see any basis
for such investigation and I I find it
very difficult to get into a discussion
of this in beauty but the prohibitions
that I think we well you answered my
question that by itself would not be a
basis no just you've been familiar with
the bureau's domestic intelligence work
for many years how did the bureau come
to launch the Co Intel program and what
in essence did COINTELPRO accomplish
well the program has such as I can
reconstruct from the files was indicated
to concern over the conspiratorial
efforts of certain groups and an attempt
to a decision made that perhaps more
affirmative action should be taken to
neutralize violence which was becoming
of more concern to the FBI in that
regard I believe these are some of the
basic considerations that went into the
launching of COINTELPRO now as far as
the first one which was the Communist
Party of course there was a concern here
to neutralize the effectiveness of the
Communist Party in the United States in
fact out of all the COINTELPRO
operations that were approved 59% of
them were directed at the Communist
Party the bulk of the concern
and initially was with the Communist
Party and it was a desire to create
factionalism within the Communist Party
and try to neutralize its efforts the
Communist Party Congress itself still
has a determination on the record as to
the threat of the Communist body in a
statute
the Supreme Court head has held that the
Communist Party is an instrument of the
Soviet Union the Soviet Union certainly
has not relinquished its interest in the
United States's of target all of these
considerations went into should we do
something
not only to follow the activities of the
Communist Party but should we destroy
its effectiveness in the United States
that was the first program I believe
that was initiated now did the bureau
ever seek direction or counsel to the
internal general law in any of its
COINTELPRO efforts or specific programs
as best as I can restructure reconstruct
senator the there was no direct
Authority requested from any Attorney
General for the initiation of these
programs and it's only a question as
your staff presented yesterday that the
Attorney General's President Congress
had been made available of certain
aspects of programs after the fact
and those were primarily concerned with
the Communist Party in oh one other
organization but not the new left and
these other types so I cannot find any
evidence that and I have no reason to
believe there would be any evidence that
the bureau initiated these programs
other than has an internal decision well
we're reports on these programs made to
the Attorney General was the inform
dozen was he kept informed on a
continuing basis he was kept informed by
letters which again the staff has an
allude
two letters reporting certain
developments for instance one of them
that went to one Attorney General
reading of that letter outlined almost
in complete detail Klan activities
activities taken to disrupt the Klan it
was used terms of neutralized disrupt
there was a clear explanation of what we
were doing against the Klan in that
regard highs that you came to believe
that you had the authority to neutralize
or disrupt these organizations rather
than proceed against the frontal is
through prosecuting them for for law
violations I guess you would have to say
in a position like this that it's just
like the Smith Act of 1940 which is
designed to prevent revolutionary groups
from advocating the overthrow of the
government and then subsequent
interpretations as to the
constitutionality of it leaves us with a
statute still on the books that
prescribe certain actions but yet the
degree of proof necessary to operate
under the few remaining areas is such
that there was no satisfactory way to
proceed and it was an area where the
senator yield effect at that point
please what you're saying to an owl is
the because of autonomous excusal is
that you didn't operate within the law
because the law didn't give you
sufficient lighting therefore you
undertook direct action to disrupt and
otherwise undermine these organizations
did you proceed on the assumption that
uh that these organizations would
eventually break the law and therefore
you saw to neutralize disruptive
did I can't say that sir I think that
they the investigations of them were
based on this belief that they might
break the law they were breaking the law
the disruptive activities I can't find
where we were able to relate it to that
what it boils down to is what we've
gotten into question before on it and
our review of the situation we see men
of the FBI recognizing or having a good
faith belief that there was an immediate
danger to the United States all right
but that's a repair to Senator Church
this question you don't say that you
really had specific legal authority for
this no and this is this is the hang-up
with a whole program and which we are
not trying to justify that there is some
statutory basis I wouldn't make that
effort whatsoever what I'm all I'm
trying to do is say that at the time it
was initiated we had men who felt there
was a an immediate danger to the country
they felt they had a responsibility to
act and having felt this responsibility
did act and this is the whole problem we
have at the present time because we do
have one we can see good evidence of
their belief there was a threat we had
cities being burned we had educational
institutions being bombed we had deaths
occurring from all of these activities
we have a situation that we didn't know
what the end was going to be we never
can look around the corner in
intelligence operations we don't know if
ultimately this might bring the
destruction of the country all we know
is we had a an extremely violent time so
I don't find any basis in my mind to
argue with their good faith belief they
were faced with a danger now when they
move over to this second area of
responsibility here's where we have the
problem and I think
the whole purpose of this committee the
Attorney General mr. Kelly all of us
realizing we can't operate in these
areas where we feel a responsibility but
we don't have a mandate by Congress so
in that area this feeling of
responsibility I feel team from the fact
that presidents as your staff said
yesterday president's congressman the
Attorney General no one really provided
direction and guidance or instructions
don't do this do this don't do that of
what are you doing and how are you doing
for instance there's some feeling in the
on the part of some that our whole
domestic intelligence operations were
secret the COINTELPRO operation was I
mean I think we all agreed that this was
to be effective they felt it should be
secret
but back in our this is printed
appropriation testimony which went to
the members of the committee was mailed
out to newspapers friends anyone that
was interested in it back in 1970
talking about our internal security
operations the new left movement young
socialists alliance Chicago trial
nationwide demonstrations student
agitation anti-war activities vince'll
Ramos Brigade Committee of returned
volunteers Communist Party USA
progressive labor court a Socialist
Workers Party extremist organizations
Black Panther Party all of these items
and statements about extremist white
extremists in hate type groups Republic
of new Afrika Minutemen our coverage of
subversive organizations the several
groups organizations and movements which
I discussed so the wide coverage we must
maintain to follow on their activities
in changing tactics in spite of the
proliferation of these organizations our
informant coverage that
levels has been a great value in
assistance and enabling us to keep
abreast of our investigative
responsibilities this is the same way
through all of our public probation
testimony we've told the world we're
investigating Blackheath group's new
left groups so I merely mentioned this
to try to put in the frame of reference
of these men feeling they know we're
investigating them they didn't tell them
though in sufficient detail or other
than scandal II before the
Appropriations Committee what we were
doing to disrupt these activities and my
feeling is that the men recognized the
danger they pointed out the danger to
the world they said we're investigating
these organizations and they felt then
that the comfortable climate had leave
it up to the FBI we should do something
more and that's what we're looking for
guidelines on the Attorney General mr.
Kelly you that give us the guidelines
under which we should operate now there
are certain guidelines that we don't
need to be given we shouldn't do this we
don't have such activities today
programs designed to disrupt or
neutralize in the domestic intelligence
field but beyond that we need guidelines
on what does the whole of Congress
representative of the people by passage
of legislation say this is the FBI's
role in domestic intelligence and that's
mr. chairman my time is long since
expired I would like to note that I saw
mr. Kelly on the Today show this morning
indicating strong support for
Responsible congressional oversight now
yes that's it that's a healthy act to
you well I think it must come because as
you have really conceded you shouldn't
have ever had to have had guidelines to
tell you that the
the federal government's chief law
enforcement agency ought not to disobey
the law and really you don't need
explicit guidelines to tell you that or
you shouldn't have
wouldn't you agree I would say that
looking at it today we should have
looked at it that way yesterday but I do
feel that I don't have any doubt about
the good faith of people recognizing a
danger feeling they had a responsibility
no matter whose quality was ours
internally or because we weren't given
the supervision we should have been
given and taking what they considered
appropriate action so their heart it is
right that the committee and the press
be worried about the treatment of a
Nobel Prize winner dr. King here an
awful lot of people who never got close
to a Nobel Prize whose name is Jones and
Smith that my review of the file show
had violence done to their First
Amendment rights and
Nobel Prize winners will always get
protection but yo potatoes doesn't this
committee should focus on him too now
included in this : tell
[Music]
were activities like this anonymous
letters drafted by bureau offices in the
field sent to headquarters in Washington
approved and then put in the mail
intended to break up marriages not of
dr. King but of Marian John Jones
because one or other was thought to be a
Alda Center might address strangely or
showed up at meetings in company of
others who dressed strangely
anonymous letters to university
officials and to the several newspapers
in that city to prevent university
facilities from being made available to
a speaker whom the bureau disapproved
and it wasn't a top-flight big-name
speaker in that case an anonymous letter
was sent to me making protests
as an anonymous letter it never occurred
to me that it came from the Federal
Bureau of Investigation the
series of anonymous letters one with the
spelling very poor the grammar sloppy
and another more sophisticated
[Music]
protesting the employment by a city of a
man alleging that he was a communist or
came from a communist family and there
are loyal Americans out of work and what
are you doing mayor and to the press
isn't this an outrage and again the love
an anonymous letter sent to me what are
you going to do about this they're loyal
Democrats in this town who need work and
in that case I happen to know I happen
to have known the man about whom the
protest was made and the bureau's facts
were wrong as hell honor on that mantle
oil but he was his loyal viewer I now
I
[Music]
yes or no are those actions regarded now
by the bureau as within bounds no sir
why were they regarded as within bounds
when they were approved by the Bureau
well I think even under the guidelines
of COINTELPRO as established the
programs were not designed for the
purpose of harassment of an individual
the memoranda indicate they're designed
to disrupt the organization some of the
turndowns were turned down on this
specific wording this is mere harassment
the rationale would have been and of
course here I say some of these you've
mentioned wouldn't even appear to me to
meet the criteria of the program and
should have been disavowed even under
the existence of the program however in
the total context of the program
activities were to be directed towards
the organization itself but we do not do
that at the present time but everything
I've summarized rather truly was
approved by the Bureau at the time by
headquarters not field officers I do
think that the there were improper
actions taken under the program even
even under the program as it existed mr.
Kelly has so stated his recognition of
that fact the Attorney General certainly
has yet the majority of the actions
taken even the department concluded were
lawful and legal proper investigative
activities but the baby my feeling is
that isn't a question of techniques
they're bad the concept of the program
seems to give do violence to the First
Amendment because everything that you
did sought to silence some money or
frighten somebody into silence or deny
somebody a platform
or create a an atmosphere in which
people were we're in fact afraid to
assemble now sometimes
law-enforcement legitimate law
enforcement has what we call this
chilling effect when it's legitimate law
enforcement often times that chilling
effect is unnecessary the regrettable
side effect but what I'm talking about
and what these files are full our
actions the only purpose of which is to
chill would you agree with me mr. Adams
that this whole vague generalized area
of the assignment that have been at the
FBI has been tasked and which they
thought they possess over years to
investigate Americans not where there
are allegations of crime or suspicions
that crimes are about to be committed or
that there's violence or that violence
is might about to be committed but
rather this whole generalized area to
investigate Americans in terms of ideas
that they have or might be persuaded to
have that might hold potential for
danger this country is an exceedingly
vague difficult if not impossible to
find area and an area which has gotten
the FBI into awful lot of trouble
including for today's hearings yes and
because of that there is a very
important need to sit down and redefine
it have the guidelines known
specifically by law so that the FBI can
know precisely what it can do and what
it cannot do I think this is why the
country is fortunate at this
particular time to have an attorney
general who is a legal scholar and a
lawyer of unquestioned repute who has
indicated a willingness to address these
problems which as the staff has
determined was not always the case over
the years but we have an attorney
general we have a director who has
offered his complete cooperation just as
he has to the committee in this inquiry
that we're not trying to avoid
embarrassment the only thing we're
trying to hold back or identities of
informants and sensitive ongoing
operations and that we have a concern on
the part of Congress that not only
recognizes there have been abuses but
recognizes that they're still always has
to be some degree of flexibility we're
going to have situations where you have
a weatherman working for the waterworks
and in college he was a scientist I mean
a scientific student and he makes a
comment that to a fellow employee that
there's going to be some speck
spectacular event occurring that's going
to bring the attention of the world on
this city now wouldn't you have probable
cause then to investigate Commission of
occurs I'd have to investigate but
because you get shocked do we have the
authority to tell the supervisor of the
waterworks you better get him out of
there before the city water is poisoned
than a hundred thousand people dying and
I think the committee is going to find
the same problems we do in groping with
that situation and even the Attorney
General in his speech in Ottawa pointed
out that there is still possibly a
necessity for some flexibility have you
any idea how many how many names of
Americans you're keeping your files all
told as a result of the cumulative
effect of all these surveillances and
the investigation
I don't know it's in the ligand we have
six and a half million files you have
six and a half million file yes sir
and and and there are surely names of
more than one person in it typically in
a file aren't there but it is a rather
large country we have line well that's a
large number of files to start with and
if you have multiple names and them were
quickly up into them into the net you
know twenty thirty forty million right
but many of these files are applicant
files they're not all subversive files
they're not all criminal files we have a
million crimes of violence each year
there's a million people sure and I'm I
wish you had more time to spend on those
crimes of violence I do too
well there were a great like what what I
worry about is this you say there's no
way to know when to close a file these
are surveillance files they were
originally opened up for to determine
whether organizations might have
subversive connections there are names
in these files
so some demagogue comes along and says
against some public figure that his name
is contained in a certain file it is to
be found in the subversive files of the
of the FBI and there it is he hasn't
made in this statement at all but for
the American people that man name and
reputation has been scarred and I hope
this committee recognizes that and
recommends legislation that would
enforce strong punitive or criminal
violations against misuse of information
in the files we feel this way CIA feels
this way we recognize we have a lot of
sensitive information in it we fire our
employees if we find the misusing
information we feel we need additional
sanctions in this area I don't think we
can ever stop the accumulation of
information I don't know an
investigative agency in the world a law
enforcement agency that doesn't act to
accumulate information
and we're working on guidelines as to
how to get rid of the irrelevant
information how to eliminate material it
really doesn't need to be kept and we
hope we'll be able to come to Congress
in with these guidelines before too long
which will help address itself to just
some of these problems
well you may be assured that the
committee shares your your objective in
this regard and and we will be working
with you and with the Department of
Justice and others to try and change the
laws to give a greater measure of
protection to the First Amendment rights
of the American people
so the hearings you've just been
watching took place in this room on
November 18th and 19th 1975 Kate Scott
is a historian how could you put this in
perspective well the the gentleman here
is in an unenviable position which is
that he's been asked to defend FBI
practices over the course of the Cold
War practices that have included
infiltrating civil rights organizations
the women's movement the anti-war
movement it's included all kinds of
projects and plans to disrupt these
these social movements and the Senators
are particularly concerned about how the
FBI's very programs have violated the
Constitution in ways that the you know
in very real ways and while the FBI is
is meant to protect the Constitution so
they're pointing to this this problem
and saying clearly we must do something
about it
the challenge here is and not to defend
the practices of the FBI but the
testimony given here is meant to provide
some context in to explain the the
history the time period in which these
programs were created and the very real
developments that these programs were a
response to so for example in the 1960s
we have a number of we have a number of
civil disturbances within Newark and
Detroit in watts California we have we
have bombs that are being detonated on
university campuses in Madison Wisconsin
in New York City we have he suggests
very real dangerous situations that the
FBI as the domestic law enforcement
agency is meant that must address and
he's suggesting that in the context of
the Cold War the very real threat of
global communism may be behind some of
these movements and that the FBI under
FBI director J Edgar Hoover who was the
director for more than 40 years has
tasked the agency with providing a type
of response to these developments the
senators are mindful of the Cold War era
in which these programs were developed
because they've been lawmakers during
this period they understand the
challenges but they're suggesting that
the FBI has gone entirely too far and as
you can see from some of their hearts
very emotional senator Phil Hart of
Michigan he has some very emotional
testimony about about how his family
members have been trying to convince him
for some time that these programs have
been in place and he has dismissed their
arguments as irrational the FBI could
never be involved in this type of
behavior
and his point is the FBI he's convinced
the FBI is involved he sees the evidence
provided by members of the committee
staff and he says we must respond we
must educate the American public about
the extent to which these programs
violated constitutional protections and
then we as lawmakers members of Congress
will have to respond with legislation to
correct that to prevent these abuses
from occurring in the future did they
respond and make legislation that
changed things well yes and no their
ultimate goal of establishing an FBI
Charter that is a legal framework that
would provide the parameters for which
the FBI could operate that was never
approved by Congress it was considered
for long for many years but it was never
finally approved the scrutiny of the FBI
and the fact that J Edgar Hoover passed
away in 1972 provided a sort of unique
opportunity for a new Attorney General
Edward Leary to institute internal
reform and he did that with a series of
processes that were known as the
Attorney General guidelines now the
criticism for those guidelines was that
they were they addressed this particular
issue but of course any Attorney General
coming in could change those guidelines
moving forward and so that therefore a
legislative recommend a legislative
solution would have been preferable a
legislative Charter would have been
preferable but ultimately it was those
internal reforms that were the the final
sort of the final reform effort the
final effort to reform the FBI that came
out of this investigation do you know
what sort of reaction there was in the
public and in news reports to the
revelations about Martin Luther King
people were deeply disappointed you can
see the lawmakers here the revelations
that the FBI had not only infiltrated
Martin Luther King journals top circle
and was collecting intelligence about
his top lieutenants if you will but the
allegations that the FBI had been what
they called wiretapping Martin Luther
King Jr's hotel room in order to gather
information that they could blackmail
him with was deeply troubling to the
general public and especially to members
of this committee the committee tried to
handle the information that they had in
a very responsible way we now know what
the the content of those wiretaps was we
know what was recorded in those hotel
rooms we now know that but at the time
during the course of this hearing the
members themselves and the staff never
revealed the content of that wiretap and
they did that very consciously they said
we don't want to further violate the
family's privacy of course it was
reported by members of the press what
the content of that material was but it
does suggest that dealing with some of
this information was very challenging
for members of the committee and their
staff because they wanted to present the
material to the American public to help
them understand these egregious abuses
and they wanted to do it in a way that
respected the individuals who had been
under surveillance and that's a
difficult that's a difficult thing to do
okay Scott thank you very much thank you